well there's always the experiments that
you do his child I was actually not some
sort of a child prodigy by any stretch
like we were you know my mom was always
helping us a science fair project like
the week before you know there's always
that kind of we were a little bit yeah
so that was a little hodgepodge I can't
say you can actually have a you know so
I'm living proof that you can be a
terrible young scientist and still have
a career I but and so I think when I got
to college was the first time I've ever
really done I mean yeah so we live one
we weren't American so we didn't really
know a lot about like all these like
summer programs and fancy things that
you could do to get like an early start
and where did I and I was pretty
clueless like I'm the kind of person
that instead of thinking oh I can you
know skip grades I was just like how am
I gonna get a hundred and everything and
do you know like as i was working within
my confines which i think is good like
sometimes if you think too far like
three steps ahead you don't really
appreciate what you have but i think my
whole education was about doing what I
could at the time um but so all of that
as backdrop I had never really even
known like what a lab was until I got to
college like really and early on in my
freshman year I joined David bartels
group and David Martel is one of the
world's leading you know when the is a
you know pioneer of RNA and
understanding sort of micrornas and how
they work so he's tremendous and yeah
and it was I was his second person in
his lab so he just started at MIT he had
a spectacular technician and then he had
me and I was I was not good i mean i
just picked at the picked up for the
first time and if you know anything
about RNA work it's very difficult
because RNA is not nearly as stable as
DNA and so you can contaminate it really
easily you can you know affect it really
easy you can be working with an artifact
and so it was a really good training and
I I like applaud David for his patience
and working with me and I think there's
a lot of times where he was like you
sure you know I think yeah I just was so
tenacious I just kind of kept going back
I think he was hoping at one one day I
would be like I don't need to do this
anymore but I stayed with him for all
four years of college and so for me it
was great because
after doing RNA as an undergraduate with
no experience everything after that
became very easy so DNA was just like
you know I could just do it blindfolded
and still make it work which was great
but it was definitely a interesting slow
start I think now the best days I mean I
there's a lot of great days I think a
lot of great days in the lab often come
with working with people so I have one
student Patrick Borelli I worked with
for the last few years he's sort of he
was my an undergraduate I worked with as
a postdoc and some of the best days were
just the two of us sitting together in a
room you know going back and forth like
you know he was he's a computer science
physics made a major but with a big
computer science training so he was
doing a lot of the more rigorous
programming we needed to do and I was
doing a lot of the analysis so we'd go
back and forth and this most recent
paper that we did where we talked about
last fever and the hair and sweatin Asia
and all sorts of things we're developing
a lot of tests and I think this six week
period where Patrick came from you know
vacation and the two of us worked 16
hours a day for six weeks just plugging
away running analysis on the genome high
five we both had like headphones going
and you know go back and forth and would
high-five each other like every time
something cool happened I think that's
the kind of stuff were it's just it was
it's funny we talked about it being like
the most fun time ever even though we
really just SAT you know woke up grab
breakfast like came in it was every day
we'd sort of like touch base and being
there is great
you